à la suite d'un récent arrêté
ministériel le lancer de nain est
interdite en france
conséquence manu un maître 18 est au
chômage il rêvait de faire du spectacle
[Musique]
en
parti tout seul tu sais pas je sois
référence
tu t'es ça va être comme ça il faut que
tu montres genre maintenant tout ce qui
tombe qui ont mal parlé de toi tu ton
jugé sans même te connaître il faut que
tu leur montre maintenant de quoi tu es
capable montrer ta vraie image parce
qu'ils t'ont pas laissé le temps de te
montrer vraiment de te dévoiler au
public
alors maintenant il faut que tu te vois
tu te bats mais que tu pars je vais pas
dans la chose en laquelle tu crois maïs
toile dans un arrêt non mais j'ai pas tu
arriveras qui ça a été enterré arrivera
il pourra le démontrer à tous ceux qui
on a parlé de toi que thomas jugé le
mangement qui tu es vraiment repris le
tuc a pas de plein de choses et chacun
chacun un point g résultat est le même
encombrement pour le document qu'on a
montré pour que le téléspectateur puisse
en juger
j'ai bien aimé la manière je veux dire
moi je monte sur scène comme ça et on a
deux qui monte sur scène autrement
moi je suis monté comme ça pourquoi
parce que j'en avais marre de me laisser
dans l'ombre ont voyagé aussi parce que
si l'on fait quelque chose pour moi je
serai pas envoyé de cinéma s'il vous
plaît
m
cité comme ça j'aurai un casque de
protection et j'avais une combinaison
avec harnais avec des des poignets et
puis les gars et vous prenez comme ça il
faisait une deux et trois ça fait mais
c'est pas tout parce que sinon ça serait
pas un spectacle c'est pour moi
j'arrivais avec une carte comme ça
j'avais deux capes argentées
je tournais comme ça ils sont tout à
fait ça et je faisais trois tours et
autres 7-6 3 tours et j'allais chez les
filles les narguer isolées scilly
balaiera non pas lui est trop longue et
trop gros ils ont même jeté contre le
mur lui se rend pas compte
puis ensuite je mettais en position et
puis le guen prenait au bout 1 2 et au
troisième il me jeter on aimerait que ça
existe dans notre pays qui comme le prix
des droits de l'homme donc de les
limiter
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait bon
l'interview au matin et on se bat pour
la dernière de ma marque en fonction de
son âge de sa saison on est
on va demander à monsieur philibert
monsieur kouchner à monsieur maxence
yeux la négation du survenu à la case
départ je suis pour morrow minaudant le
la vie que j'étais avant quoi c'est quoi
cette vie cette vie c'est si on peut
appeler ça une vie derrière parce que
ces mots simples sais c'est pas bien
c'est comme ça la maison et rien faire
moi je supporte pas il faut que je fasse
quelque chose de mes dix doigts vous éco
avant rien s'alarme vous gagner plus
voilà j'ai touché pas de chômage qui
touchait une pension doivent être
d'adultes handicapés dont j'ai gardé
qu'il n'a donné qu'un an et ensuite j'ai
pu rien eu ma mère les simples et femme
de ménage je ne pouvais pas mais cette
bosse et qui tous les gens qui sont
contre
bon d'accord mais c'est pas vu qu'il me
contacte tu as pris ta taille pour
monter sur la scène j'en fais pareil je
me regarde en face moi en balance les
matins c'est tout ce que je pense que
j'aurais pu faire quoi on est c'est pas
bien leur part c'est pas gentil de l'an
passé ces mêmes mais ce qu'on sait c'est
pas bien ce qu'ils ont fait non
cette pollution
[Musique]
brodeuse aux managers
ça fera des menus à leur bonne et
heureuse année à commencer par le
consensus
maintenant si interbox et gym rageur
non ils ont rien compris ils voient
disant tu vends plus tôt
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est qu'ils ont interdit à la
presse ou des jets mais pas une
convocation n'est pas rien et rien comme
quoi j'ai près ils m'ont trouvé ça on
sent rien du tout il semblait si l'on
trouve comme j'étais avant
voilà écoutez la première fois que
j'avais vu vraiment que manuel et
s'était mis un but dans la tête tu vois
en étant en étant la seule commune de
bananes et de but de manu depuis que
c'était de réussir
voilà c'était de réussir c'est tout ça
moi je comprends pas pourquoi une
personne tu veux réussir donc mais
devant lui coupa la ligue mais surtout
en plus seulement les couples sous leur
niveau dans une émission aussi écouté
que sabathia s'est jamais conclu
c'est à dire ce que toi tu roulais vers
ce que tu voulais vous montrer ce qu'il
voulait devenir en bas c'était
complètement autre chose que ce qu'on a
vu à la télé ce qu'on a vu à la télé
c'était quelque chose
la sortie de son contexte c'était un
truc qui était peut-être un peu choquant
mais ils n'ont jamais compris dans quel
esprit pratique ne sait exactement comme
un clown par exemple qui prend un point
aux fesses puis quand il est sur sur une
scène tout le monde trouve ça rigolo et
c'est sûr que si on prend la même scène
complètement sortie de son contexte ça
devient ça devient peut-être un futur
mais là pour toi c'était pas ça ils ont
absolument pas respecté l'esprit dans
lequel tu pouvais faire ça il t'aide
moralement les copains oui mais dois je
me suis fait une très bonne amie qui
s'appellent sandrine qui mêle vachement
qui me soutient moralement et qui veille
sur moi ou quoi qui oui ça fait plus de
sept ans je la connais elle est super
les correct elle est franche et les elle
est bien comme si j'aime bien j'ai
jamais eu de problème avec elle
[Musique]
je te dis à bientôt
pas de champion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense que lui seul peut décider de ce
qu'il a fait ou non quoi et qu'il faut
plus qu'il se laisse abattre comme ça
par des gens qui à la limite on leur
carrière toute tracée et que manu il a
envie de se faire une carrière et puis
bon je pense qu'il y arrivera par
n'importe quel moyen
[Applaudissements]
ils m'ont dit tu vas vais faire des
spectacles faire du cinéma enfin devenir
quelqu'un quoi parce que j'ai vu la
taille que j'ai je vois mal faire autre
chose quoi j'ai eu la possibilité de
faire cerveau pour un début c'est bien
si j'aurais eu une carrière présent par
les bilans cinéma je relis ton message
fallait dans le cinéma je refrappe été
un dur et fiable de tous pour apprendre
un peu comment apprendre apprendre la
vie d'acteur quoi
[Musique]